Hi there! This is Steve Kaufmann.
Today I want to talk about something that I often
think about, when it comes to language learning.
And that is the relationship between
language learning and the jigsaw puzzle.
And I think of it all the time as I'm
learning Russian and, all of a sudden,
a new piece of the puzzle,
basically, clicks for me.
And the relationship is this: that with a jigsaw
puzzle you begin with a lot of little pieces
that don't look like anything;
there's no image, you have no idea
how you can possibly get from
that to the completed picture.
But as you proceed to put the
little pieces together, guessing;
you find two that kind
of look like each other,
that they belong together,
you put them together.
And often by chance you find
one that fits in, and of course,
the biggest thing about a jigsaw puzzle is:
the more of the picture that you start to see,
the easier it is then to
find the pieces that fit in.
You start to sense
what you're looking for.
And in language learning
I've always felt that
there are certain things that
I won't be able to make sense so,
until I have a lot of the other
pieces of the puzzle in there.
So, in the case of Russian,
some of the cases will...
I will start to notice them.
And as they become obvious
and I start to take them for granted, then
I focus on some other pieces of the puzzle.
The same is true with, you know,
verbs in French or Spanish.
If you're given a whole bunch
of verbs or a whole bunch of,
in the case again, German
or Russian, noun endings,
you can't possibly
absorb them.
But as you put some of the pieces together,
then the other pieces start to fit in.
And, in the case of verb endings, always
some tenses or some endings will remain more
difficult than others, you may
always have trouble with them.
But it's a lot easier to cope with that
when the other pieces are already in place.
I mean the same is true with colors,
if you're presented with a whole list of colors
you can't possibly absorb
all those names of colors.
But as some of the colors start to slot in,
it then becomes easier to learn the other colors.
The same with days of the week,
the same with months of the year,
the same with any aspect of the language
if it comes at you as one great whole set
that you have to try to understand,
to learn as a set,
the parts of the body or whatever.
It's very difficult to absorb it.
Just like the loose pieces
of the jigsaw puzzle,
but as some of the shape forms,
and the image start to take shape,
then it becomes easier to
learn the other pieces.
And I think it's important
to remember that
to particularly when you think
you're making very little progress,
slowly different things
start to slot into place.
But in order for them to slot into place
you have to try to notice,
you have to be consciously aware
of those pieces that you have
and those pieces that
you don't yet have.
So, just a short comment
there on the importance of
being aware that learning a language
is picking up a lot of bits and pieces
very often incidentally and that the
more you have the more you can learn.
And that's again another reason why
you need to keep at it, constantly,
and focus largely on things
that you like doing and,
in particular, on consuming a lot
of content - listening and reading -
or putting yourself in
situations where you,
interacting with people
and you're struggling to find
those missing pieces and
by struggling a few times,
eventually, you'll start to
notice them somewhere
and then they become part
of the language for you.
I hope that's helpful
to some people.